[Music]
[Applause]
this is our home now
i want us to fit in oh this is gonna be
a gaffe
where did you two move from how long
have you been married and why
don't you have children yet our story
i think what my wife means to say is
that we moved for
move from where married when damn it why
oh arthur stop it stop it
stop it stop it
[Music]
am i dead no why would you think that
because you are
each day
we are an unusual couple you know oh i
don't think that was ever in question
welcome back everyone it's charlie
surprise surprise this is going to be my
one division trailer video they dropped
it at the emmys there's a whole bunch of
footage a bunch of easter eggs from the
comics and avengers end game
so we'll explain what's going on they're
setting up a bunch of marvel phase 4
x-men stuff it's going to be crazy and i
will be doing episode videos when it
does release
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get everything we'll do
a disney plus giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the trailer on
the video
so we'll just go through this shot by
shot and talk about the easter eggs as
we go along
the biggest thing first if they're using
that sort of 1950s tv
motif with the static as the marvel logo
comes on they've been teasing the idea
that this is taking place in an
alternate reality where she's able to
change
things and things just don't obey the
normal laws of physics like later in the
trailer you see monica rambo
come in like she's coming in from
another universe like traveling the
multiverse in a space suit
then you see her covered in scarlet
witch's red energy flying across the
screen
within the context of the series she's
an agent of sword that nick fury space
station is the sword space station from
the comics so they're going to be
explaining what they've been doing
since the end of avengers end game but
the trailer begins with them in this
seemingly 1950s
tv environment it's in black and white
they're driving in a 1950s car
into the suburbs it says just married on
the back of their car which is something
out of the scarlet witch and vision
comic book the miniseries from a long
time ago
it sounds like that's where the series
picks up their relationship begins and
she finds a way to bring him back
through the multiverse
because later in the trailer you see
katherine hahn who's seemingly the
antagonist of the series
teasing vision you're dead basically
telling him you're not supposed to be
alive
it seems like she's supposed to be a
version of agatha harkness based on a
lot of the behind the scenes that we've
seen so far so it kind of makes sense
that she's messing with them and
manipulating scarlet witch in her
fragile state as she's trying to relive
or have a version of a life with vision
even though he's supposed to be dead
it's not really clear how she winds up
in this pocket reality but she tells
vision after they walk into the house
and after they've been married we want
to fit in with our environment here so
in a very 1950s funny way he changes his
appearance like they're using 1950s
graphics to sort of
fit with the motif of the 1950s
television show that they're living in
right now
if you're a fan of that 70s show that's
deborah joe rupp she was the mom from
that 70s show so it's funny to see her
pop up in this
she makes a reference to children
obviously that's wiccan and speed that
we see later in the trailer the twins
that they're holding when it seems like
they're in the 1980s maybe that's when
they're in the family ties era that's
kind of what this house looks like
or maybe full house it just depends on
what kind of references you think
they're making with the different
eras here but you do notice that she's
using her abilities
inside this alternate reality like she's
levitating the wine bottle pouring the
wine
whatever these other people are whether
they're real or not it seems like they
start to glitch out just a little bit
like whatever this alternate reality
pocket dimension they're living in it's
just not completely a hundred percent
so the little cracks start to show in
the seams for some reason it seems like
vision doesn't know that he's supposed
to be dead
so she probably didn't tell him but it
does seem like he knows who he is and
what his abilities are because he sort
of looks at scarlet witch when their
guests start to glitch out a little bit
like what's going on here
we need to hide this then it seems like
scarlet witch changes their reality into
the 1960s looking tv show and everything
goes into color
then they have a big montage with them
dancing their way through the brady
bunch reality of the 1970s then
obviously you see the twins wicked in
speed
you see catherine hans character who
seems like she might be agatha harkness
just showing up at various points in
their house in the different eras
so it sounds like she also definitely
knows that this is not supposed to be
real
you get a little more context for her in
the comic book scarlet witch costume
this is obviously taking place during
the halloween time where vision is
actually floating around
in his full comic book form but i do
love
the og vision costume that he's wearing
so remember this is what vision is
supposed to look like his base form
but this is him creating a fake uniform
for himself based on his original
comic book uniform i wouldn't be
surprised if some of the other kids in
the background
are easter eggs to their halloween
costumes but it's a little hard to pick
them out at this size here
it's still not totally clear why
catherine han is messing with them
because it sounds like she has something
to do with vision and scarlet witch
winding up in this alternate reality
making this possible for her
if you look at the license plate at the
beginning of the trailer here too it
says
number 102 i think that's an easter egg
for avengers 102
which is a grim reaper vision story
about him
getting a new life so that might have
something to do with what agatha
harkness is doing maybe she makes some
sort of bargain
but in the original avengers comic book
story the grim reaper
wanted vision to help him take down the
avengers if he would have said yes to
that deal the grim reaper would have
transferred vision's mind into wonder
man's body
which was a bit of a dark twist on his
original origin story in the comics
so maybe scarlet witch is the one that
makes the deal with agatha harkness and
that's how vision winds up coming back
but it winds up being some big twist
that completely spins out of control
you see scarlet witch using her reality
warping powers for the comics for the
first time
to change their environment sort of
evolve them up through the different
decades of television
so this is just them doing more comic
book scarlet witch powers
kevin feige did say that they were
taking her full-blown comic book scarlet
witch during this so it just seems like
this is the beginning of that
there's probably just a whole bunch of
this going on during the series you see
monica rambo flying across the frame it
seems like she's flying from day to
night it's hard to tell if these are two
of the same scenes together or if
they're just two separate scenes
it kind of looks like she's cracking
into this energy barrier here so that
might be her crossing into this other
dimension but it seems like she comes
in inside a spacesuit but once she
enters this reality
she's in period-specific clothing like
whatever this alternate reality is
it automatically changes the clothes
that she's wearing then a really big
deep cut easter egg here too if you
notice
this person in the background the
military that sort of rides up looking
for her
it's ray wise he was also on the agent
carter tv series as the head of roxanne
as hugh jones so it's just funny to see
actors pop up in multiple different
roles
inside the mcu but i'm assuming that
this military group is probably
associated with the agents of sword
then they just make that funny reference
back during the 1950s era about them
being an unusual couple
i don't think that was ever in question
because she was going out with an
android
so obviously there's a lot of big
questions about what else is going on
during this they want to give you a
little bit of the stuff that's happening
outside of this false reality that she's
living in
most of it's all just the different
decades of television and them having
their family together like they do in
the comics they said that's basically
the first half of the show but the
second half of the series blows up into
something that's a little more akin to
traditional big mcu movie action
so it just sounds like they're doing a
lot of the big highlight beats
from the scarlet witch comic book story
so doing a bit of her chaos magic
her reality warping powers her children
with vision
there's been a lot of rumors about what
they're doing with her children because
they are mutants so this is sort of like
the dawn of mutants in the mcu in a much
bigger way
but supposedly during the series the
children will sort of age up and they'll
eventually bring them back in a young
avengers associated project
which they supposedly are setting up
during the ant-man 3 movie
this is also going to be crossing over
with doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness i think that gets into what's
happening with
monica rambo crossing over between
dimensions into this alternate reality
space
and once things sort of spin out of
control it threatens the main mcu
reality and that's when doctor strange
gets involved because he's all about
protecting
our reality or the reality of the main
mcu agatha harkness is also a bit of a
crossover character with a lot of the
x-men comics doctor strange
and obviously scarlet witch mostly
central to scarlet witch's story
but if you were looking for more good
news supposedly they will be releasing
one division during december like they
originally planned because it was a
trailer earlier this week which listed
it coming during
2020. there's a lot of questions about
what's going to happen to falcon and
winter soldier there was an earlier
promo for disney plus that they released
at the emmys and it had a bunch of
different footage from the mandalorian
season two in falcon and winter soldier
but they took the release date off of
falcon and winter soldier and it just
says
coming soon now so what might wind up
happening is they just released those
episodes after they released the one
division episodes
there's also been rumors that there
might be up to nine episodes of one
division instead of the original six
they're still finishing a little bit of
filming on both of those shows you
probably saw the recent falcon and
winter soldier behind the scenes stuff
you see a whole bunch of sharon carter
make
all the captain america chris evans
instagram jokes that you want
they're even bringing bat rock the
leaper back he could be associated with
mcu thunderbolts that they're setting up
on that show and during the end of the
black widow movie
there's also rumors about them doing
more black widow disney plus release
stuff
what's probably gonna happen is is
there's a big disney investor meeting
october
7th that's probably when they'll reveal
the official release dates for falcon
winter soldier one division and
hopefully give us a definitive answer
about what they're doing with the black
widow movie
they're still in the middle of filming
the loki series right now too that won't
release till sometime spring next year
but remember all the movies have been
delayed just a little bit so it's going
to be shang chi
in february unless they bump black widow
to february hopefully they won't bump
the movies that much more
but if you spotted any of the big easter
eggs during the one division trailer
that i didn't mention in the video
just write them below in the comments
and of course i'll be doing episode
videos for when it gets here
and more trailer videos as they release
more footage wait wait for everything
click here for the star wars mandalorian
season 2
trailer video and click here for my
black panther 2 chadwick boseman video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]